[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo what's going on everybody welcome
back to the stream it's been a minute
since we've done this together um
wow it's been about a month a lot has
happened in a month what's going on
everybody you see me do you hear me
like technical difficulties are lurking
around the corner
all right so there may be some on the
stream you know how it goes
um but we're gonna do our best so this
is a very awesome stream i'm very
excited for this because i think this
could actually be
like a thing that we can do once a month
um it's a way to involve you guys and
it's a way to
you know for all of us to learn so
here's what we're gonna do all right
um first off let me let me just hop on
over
so we got peter france up in the house
what's going on peter
what's up everybody hey buddy it's good
to be here thank you yeah i need cheers
man
i feel like i'm on a talk cheers
oh cheers we got our sparkling waters i
got my tea and my sparkling water it's
hot and cold fire nice
yeah we're doing it all coffee and
sparkling water very well hydrated
absolutely
we got the dehydrator and the hydrator
all good to go
um but no i'm super excited this is a
great idea i love
speed modeling so yeah so here's what
we're gonna do let me let me give you
guys the lowdown so basically we got six
rounds
all right me and peter are going to go
six rounds
um speed modeling the first two rounds
are gonna be five minute rounds all
right we have five minutes to do
whatever you guys suggest
i have a pinned comment in the chat go
to that link um
post a picture of what you want us to
speed model as well as just
one word of text for what that thing is
and we actually got sotomonte one of the
moderators for the
for the discord server he's behind the
scenes and he's going to be updating
this prompt
um as we create right so
you know go go don't go easy on us all
right like lay it down
um yeah i want some weird suggestions
like something really out there
absolutely yeah um i think the harder
and the more ridiculous the funnier it's
gonna be so
yeah like i said six rounds the first
two rounds are five minute rounds
um the next two rounds
are ten minute rounds and then the final
two rounds are 30 minute rounds
all right so we're gonna kind of get
warmed up and then
as we get into those later rounds we're
actually going to take some time and
like hopefully we can all learn
something together so
that's not it two other things that
makes this
super cool so um first off speed model
with us do this challenge with us open
blender open c4d open maya 3ds max
whatever the heck you guys use
open it grab a pad of paper and pen
draw it with us let's do speed drawing
too whatever it'd be sweet
um and just challenge yourself with us
but if you guys aren't going to do that
then it throw suggestions our way
all right so this involves everybody the
link is pinned
in the comments here um in the live chat
go there check it out um
drop some suggestions so dimonte is
going to pick his favorites
and update each uh each round for us
live here so
quite the production um thank you chris
i see you man you've actually helped me
out a whole lot thank you for the super
chat
um making some big moves in the future
i'm very excited this
this channel is gonna be doing some big
things and um chris has helped me out
with some cool ideas and scisheron good
to see you again
good to be back man thanks for hanging
out um
peter psy's asking how you doing man
what's going on
dude i'm vibing i'm chilling i'm just
i've just been having a nice time taking
life slow
live in uh in la here me and my roommate
are working on a
little vr game that i'm going to be
posting more about in the near future so
you guys can
expect to hear about that very exciting
very challenging but really fun
um kind of a retro shooter game
but yeah just been chilling been vibing
you know trying to stay healthy and
you've been doing rock climbing yeah how
are you doing what's going on
wait are you can you hear me what what
rock climbing you've been rock climbing
yeah yeah oh i've been rock climbing a
lot i'm still
like a beginner definitely but my i got
my calluses you know my fingers are
getting a little stronger
been going a few times a week it's a
good time me and clint are going to be
uh
going rock climbing outside so maybe
we'll post a vlog or something
we'll definitely get some outside climbs
i've been going at night with my buddy
jan
so definitely gonna make that happen so
y'all
let's uh let's freaking do this we got
people we got a thousand people up in
here
let's get to speed bottling
all right so as you can see um peter's
in blender i'm in c4d
we got five minutes on the clock uh we
don't know what the prompt is we got
sodamonte
one of the the main discord moderators
that he was basically the first along
with uh deerin
and he's gonna he's gonna be dropping it
like it's hot for us all right so
hopefully
this first one uh we'll see what we can
do here
but um soto i know you can hear me
um peter are you ready
oh i'm i'm ready i got my default cube
ready to go
is that a default default sphere indeed
yeah you know
you know balancing it out you know let's
balance it out everyone get ready here
we
go we'll start in a minute you know what
one minute you know what peter here
i'll match you oh snap okay how many
polygons
yeah 16 rings by 32 sides um y'all these
super chats are coming in frederico
thank you
um uh greetings from portugal y'all are
inspiration good work happy renders
thank you sir
we're doing what we can man um and best
sites p speed model peter's face with
mustache
i mean hey wait we will here's the thing
you got to hit that discord
there's a pin link uh in the live chat
here
um it's in the discord server there's
also a link in the description
and there's an ideas and a submissions
um
oh that's the other thing i didn't
mention as you guys do this post
your post your submissions in the
submission
uh channel on the discord and i'm gonna
look at them we're gonna look at them
between each round
so we're all in this together guys yeah
i can't wait to see everybody's
we're gonna laugh crappy models
okay like including our including our
don't worry guys that's going to be
chill um
so is everyone ready you guys got your
pads of paper and your
pens and your mouses and tablets and all
that ready to go
i'm ready to go let's go um
soto do it
oh snap a dive moment wow
okay let's go a dive helmet okay i mean
i'm glad i spawned the sphere
yeah um
where's my gizmo oh
right that's more of a tube situation
uh
dude so the trick is like
it's like that beeple thing you know
where it's like uh have a version
to get out you know don't don't get
stuck
not having something to to deliver you
know you got to have
something so that's what i'm going for
here
oh my god
wow this is a tough shape
okay what do i okay i'm just gonna i'm
not even a freaking like it's like a
plane
with with a little warbly on it
and
such a weird shape okay
oh man um
i know this is choking man i'm joking i
can feel the eyes on me
you need like something like that
go two by two not going to help things
okay here's what
if i just could like bend this thing
boom
gotta you just gotta hurry up uh two two
three minutes
are you serious we have three minutes
left all right i'm gonna
start not being surprised with this
something like something like that
oh would i dive with this helmet
that's the yeah we have to 3d print and
dive with these afterwards
you imagine oh my god
oh caps caps
oh get off
3d print and dive these they have to be
functioning
okay i kind of have everything except
for like
oh wow your spacecraft i need the
crisscross applesauce thing
oh why don't we do a disc
a little bit of a little bit of who
bring out a little bit
get a little bit of fill it on there
filet it fry it just right
the right amount of fried edges
um y'all we really appreciate these
super chats thank you thank you
um okay how am i gonna do the crisscross
situ
situation i have an idea going in
do like some straight up loop selection
bam wham
blam okay and then we're just
hitting these little pieces this may not
be exact but hey
uh like checker
like checkers uh
yeah i'm just doing the shittiest
checkers you've ever seen
they're fine it's like a death star
situation uh
oh what the heck what happened to my
sphere
why oh is there anything else i can do
to this
kinda is what it is uh we have 30
seconds dude 30 seconds
oh my jesus okay uh extrude enter
i mean there it is i guess maybe some
rivets i don't think i have time for
rivets
oh no i have to bevel the edges 10
seconds
okay loop selection
okay i'm done time zero that's it
time's up what do you have stop editing
all right that's that bad dude
damn how the i promised with that son i
mean you got the same thing
damn you got the same situation
heck yeah oh boy that was great that was
really really fun
i like your checker situation i think
that worked out i like that a little bit
better
mine's kind of like a weird thank you i
was thinking about doing like a nice
array modifier but then i was just like
[ __ ] it plain
yeah duplicate it yeah duplicate it
rotate it
totally boolean it yeah i'm gonna get
some yeah
see here let's go to the top oh yeah
we're getting some submissions
heck yeah heck yeah noah good stuff jack
the hack good stuff
nice very nice everyone yo everyone got
the shape
this is so good like everyone got the
shape of this no one
wow vol vol tk really nailed it
this is really good here um
yo this is fun already this is great
already uh
arthopex that's solid you got like the
subsurface
or not subsurface but the uh the
smoothing on it
really good stuff spuddy yup amazing
yeah this is all good stuff everybody
wow we have so many submissions
ed l you're right objetude
so many good ones yeah we got some speed
sketching up in here
good stuff
sick everyone did a really good job
um oh peter i don't think i have
your mic up in this let me add your mic
really quick
um but it's chill
won't bear with me y'all we're just
going to add peter's mic to this discord
setup
um guest camera
what up peter
yeah these are looking good right here
and give me some test levels
hey hey hey what's up peter franz
another very exciting
cool yeah so the biggest thing that i'm
seeing here is everyone managed like
literally
everyone managed to capture the shape
and the essence of this thing and that's
the most important thing like if you're
down
crunch down to the wire you want to
uh make sure that whatever you're
creating
uh does the job and all of these do the
job
so this is really cool to see everyone
like focusing on the main shapes and not
getting stuck on the details like
we have so many submissions everyone's
doing a good job here yeah
i was i was watching a tick tock uh
last night about this guy who's like a
very good drawer
and he was saying how drawing is less
about making something look
exactly like what you're trying to draw
and more about like
conveying the idea of what you're trying
to draw and so
it can be pretty abstract but as long as
you have those shapes
and enough like points to focus on in
your brain
you can really convey any idea and it
doesn't have to be like perfect
actually yeah it's about the feeling and
the essence versus like oh it's got to
be just right you know it's gotta be
just right
um so good work everybody you guys
nailed that first one we did um
diver helmet five minutes on the dive
moment that's round one
we got five more rounds left we're gonna
do another five minute round
um i think you guys are in the ideas
section right now
dropping ideas for sodomonte um
he's gonna present us with the next
submission so as soon as i switch over
actually soto if you could cue up the
question mark so that we can get ready
and then then present the image
once everyone's a little settled so i'm
switching over to
our working screen here
and yep we got another question mark on
it let me reset the timer
real quick here all right
this is i'm not gonna be so precious
about this one i'm just diving in head
first
using my diving helmet great all right
let me minimize this let's bring up
our c4d digging it
um i'm just going to save all this stuff
because this is super cool
and we should do like a museum for all
these
like a five-minute one or like a you
know the 10-minute
that would be great i was thinking about
uh
maybe doing a vr museum in unreal yes
yes
walk around and look at all the three
demons i i've been thinking of something
similar
um doing something for like all the
community weekly challenges or something
or like
yeah i think it could be really sweet so
guys um
for those of you just joining us we got
2 000 people up in here thank you so
much
we got the lovely peter jay france
joining us
um it's super chill to be doing this
with you man thanks for coming back this
is like your third time i think
on the stream um of course i mean
i always have a good time you know we're
buddies and so it's just a chance to
hang out and do some giving away
time on a saturday is chill man i really
appreciate that so
um and and so does everybody else
so guys um what we're doing right now
we're doing speed modeling challenges
we're on round
two out of six this is our this is our
last five minute round and then we're
gonna go on ten minute rounds okay
um if you guys wanna submit suggestions
this is live suggestions from y'all
there's a discord link pinned to the
live chat there's also a discord link in
the description of this video
go there go to the submissions uh or the
ideas
channel right on the top left of the
discord and you guys can
give a picture and a text uh like a
prompt
and sotomante is working behind the
scenes our moderator and he's prompting
us here
we have not seen these we don't know
what we're gonna model right this is
just live off the freaking top of the
dome here
um so with that
i think we're ready to hop into the
round two
this is our last five minute round okay
is everyone ready
take your last sips
let's do it okay all right soto
hit it
strand cat
all right i know exactly how i'm doing
this okay
uh let's go into a little a little front
view situation here
this is me the janky so i'm gonna finish
this in like two seconds
sketch spline sketch tool
oh that's smart
it's so good i love this picture just
got it
is it closed closed
probably best way to do this
these two bridge or
weld where are you at mr weld
okay uh let's hit it with the extrude
and we need the caps
there we go
i probably could have done this a little
a little better um
well peter your your screen is like
glitched out but i think that's just the
problem
you know let's just say it's the prompt
okay
yeah it works it's it's thematically
relevant
oh my god undo too many polygons
um
i feel like there's a hunch to this
thing i'm gonna like
oh yeah it has has like a hunch going on
um best way to do this
grab like
guys do a soft selection
it doesn't work with black
maybe a bend modifier
well let me get let me get to a point
where it's actually a thing
eyes yeah peter
why is it so jinky
okay these are definitely like more
squished
something something like this
i'm kind of done we have a minute left
okay oh damn yours looks good
i mean i don't know that i don't know if
i'd call that good
oh boy rough
i mean i feel like i could bevel the
edges
oh no dude
i think i just crashed the system oh
that was close that was close oh
oh my god oh no i think i just crashed
my system
i'd i'll clamp oh janky oh no
what is happening uh
i get an hdri in here with my extra time
19 you have 20 seconds
dude am i rendering on my cpu oh no
oh no okay we're good
[Laughter]
it's basically time dude wow oh my god
like set up that camera angle perfect
it's like kind of top down
a little bit oh my god
that's so good why dude that's so good
it's so freaky i kind of love this
character it's a really funny character
i love how you like your geometry is
definitely way cleaner than mine
um like mine
things yeah we went about it differently
how did you do yours what was your
technique i i started with a sphere
and i just like extruded it uh
different pieces like very low poly and
then i added a
subdivision surface modifier on top of
it to smooth everything out
so i just modeled like a super low poly
version at first and then
that's the way to go man look at that
hunch wait go to his back
what happened to his back dude it has so
much like
added weight
dude the traps on this guy
we need to uh oh my god
give him give him some abs give him some
the two pieces of muscle going down each
side of the spine
and then like yeah the like
the uh the airplane pillow neck
[Laughter]
exactly airplane pillow neck right it's
like he's swallowed
six golf balls that are conveniently
placed
some lats excellent lats on this on this
lad
oh my god i'm so sorry for this poor
thing
creature wow let's check out everyone
else's work
dude yours is yours looks like the most
like a it's just
it's just janky like i was like let's go
for the fastest thing
possible uh yeah using the the sketch
spline sketch uh tool it worked out it
worked out for what it was
um let's check everybody's these
are hilarious let's see
in the chat yeah where's the reset yeah
oh here we go here we go here we go
uh it's like it's got so much sass
entude tinum did a really good job on
his
that's solid is this really seriously
what oh no it's volume model god i think
it's
yeah i think it's volume oh yeah like uh
what's called yeah yeah metabolism this
one looks like x-ray essay looks like an
eraser
oh my god what is monkey for what the
heck
oh my goodness oh that's terrifying what
is up
that's so good wow oh this the the conic
form too kind of looks like the football
yeah i was about to say it i like that
dude
damn i got a hair son like i just busted
into the door
these are so good
lily wizard got it for sure
yeah definitely it's it's about the tube
yeah
it's the hip that's like thrown out
yeah this one's another eraser mdk nice
dude the robozord version fancy shoes
hope that's pretty good um coal
coalescence is really good
the beefy one general custards beefy
kidney baby
shiver j i'm gonna say shiver j has the
most
accurate oh wow it's really good
yeah that's really good yeah
wow these are awesome so much fun
dude i think this is a thing i think
this is a thing we can do this like once
a month or something
oh absolutely yeah oh great
oh my god ed l has a whole scene i'm not
even at it yet
there's so many yeah
i know there's so many seven more like
it just keeps going dude
oh my god mitch mitch is this all like
polygoned out
that's cool there's a lot
dude arya's looks like that one
character from uh before christmas
spinning
i don't know i haven't seen a boogie man
yeah yeah we went on the nightmare
before christmas themed
haunted mansion ride at disney and like
it we got stuck right at that guy's part
where he was like doing his dance in his
song for like 30 minutes
oh my god yeah i was wrong i will always
remember getting stuck there
was it like a good time or you it was
fine it was just like me and kim and we
were chilling
you know these are all great everyone
got the vibe
um oh a zottles is really cool i like
that
through in the extra little flare
um oh my god
uh you know the sketch looks incredible
echogold
echogol did a sketch that looks sick um
adrian did a sketch
saddle with the hdri very nice
um great
there's too many there's so many to look
at um
good job good job with yours
these are awesome yo furry mon has one
with like really long sexy legs
[Laughter]
this is great everybody good work
everyone got it like they're doing you
guys are doing funny stuff
congrats i want to see
an animation with like uh uh an army of
all
single one yeah all of these like like
charging at you
yeah like you there there's so many all
you hear is like you hear
and it's just like
yeah as you get over two guys there's so
many of these
that's great oh cool um ask a 501 has
both of the sketches on paper it's
really cool
like together yeah these are all good
good stuff guys
very good stuff
nice yeah good job okay um
let me scroll the bottom yeah we're at
the bottom here good stuff um
so we're gonna hop back in we're gonna
do
our first 10 minute round here so let me
reset the timer um
let's get this timer popping off uh
bear with me momentarily oh
timer back up to not five hours
um peter you having a good time man
nah man i'm having a really horrible
time i
i don't want to understand didn't you
you said you had like plans in like five
minutes right
yeah i actually um i have my friends
plans in a bit
that's cool singing just yeah like what
like two or three minutes you think
yeah even like right now would be great
because i'm pretty tired of this so then
like i'm gonna like yeah no
no cheers you got your spicy water going
cheers
yeah there's spicy water love it
all right um little cucumber key lime
popping off with some key lime right now
now i gotta ask are you oh my god
somebody has the uh
the cat holding the uh diver helmet
that's funny okay let me reset the timer
briefly
right eight so this is
round three all right we're going into
two ten minute rounds all right
uh we don't know what we're going to
model but it's going to be awesome
sodamonte's working behind the scenes
and he's pulling your suggestions
um if you guys are just joining us 2 200
people up in the chat thank you guys
for hanging out with us thank you for
the super chats i really appreciate
everybody
it's hard to get to a mall but just want
to shout out john thank you for the
super chat sir
uh we got uh who else do we got we got
uh karkuta karketa uh thank you for the
super chat
um the list goes on and on shoot
if i missed anyone else i apologize um
but it's a good time thank you guys for
your support thank you for your time
and we're going into round three this is
10 minutes all right we got double the
amount of time on this one
and we have no idea what we're gonna do
leave a submission
um suggestion for us there's a link
pinned
right up here in the live chat so
peter are you ready
i'm
all right now i've seen ej over at
idesign do this
and i'm wondering
imma start with a cube
i think i think so yeah
okay
okay
loop selection t for scale see how this
down
kl gonna be
cut tool make a little cut in here
scale this guy up a little bit so i'm
doing the low poly version
and then i'm going to do like a
subdivision
surface
yeah i mean that's such a great way to
model anything i like how we're doing
this so differently too
yeah i would have thought we would do it
pretty similar
there
hmm
this is gonna be tough dude dude yeah
this is not tough for me
no you got it you got it
wow you certainly
are you got something going there you
definitely got something going
um yeah i guess
it's a little weird [ __ ] but uh better
than this
we're working on i don't know what this
is this is a shoe
like a cankle
how often do you model peter
how often do you model
how often do you model stuff
um yeah a lot yeah because i'm i'm
always making
assets and stuff for games and for the
patreon and
you got a patreon
yes i'm going to be posting all these
models on my uh
patreon if anybody's interested in my
junkies is there a link
or do you have a like what do you like a
slash something
um yeah let me let me check i think it's
just like you should take
five minutes to check what that would be
um while i work on my model
yeah it's just uh patreon.com peter
france if anybody's interested
got some cool 3d scan assets coming out
and about
uh oh hecky i did a day and uh i also
made a blank generator
so uh yeah it's a little blender object
you
uh you can generate an egg shape and uh
specify whether it's cooked or not
whether it has pepper on it
and uh it has bubbling displacement so
if anybody needs
heck yeah thanks we'll be
releasing a patreon probably this month
i think
i can't wait to see that i mean you got
so much good
hell yes
just trying to get the shape down you
know
ape
ah you might my control key is so
rusty i've spilled too much like pretzel
dust into it
wow dude you're you're killing it
yeah you're killing it
this is looking good too you actually
have like yeah i'm trying to get that
base shape down but i think i need to
move on to
the other features before it's too late
uh we got less than five minutes
yeah i should probably like start with a
bill
oh hell yeah i'm getting some people
subscribing to the patreon thanks y'all
got some uh got some new stuff coming
out
in the next couple days it's awesome man
it's gonna be sweet ma
yeah yeah you know what gotta
get up to the patreon yeah
like i mean how how much of it is like
manageable for you versus like
it feels like a burden to like
constantly you feel like you're always
behind in like
trying to post you know what i mean yeah
i just you know it's
the nice part about it is that i'm
always working on stuff
so i have things to post just like
assets that i'll make
for my own things that i can post and
hopefully other people will get some use
out of it but you know i've i've been
really slacking because you know just
working at corridor
didn't have much time to do that stuff
but
these days i've got a ton of time and uh
i've been working on a ton of stuff so
you can start uploading more regularly
and giving people
actual bang for their buck which
i regrettably haven't always done it's
cool you know you do what you can right
you know we're working on it
yeah like what i'm doing with this duck
[Laughter]
oh boy dude wow this is not good
not good
if you saw this on turbosquid it would
be going for or it would be free
mine would definitely be the free one
yeah there's no in between
it's either way too expensive or
like weirdly amazing and completely free
no mine's free because it's
janky as all dude
i'm going to make mine all kind of yeah
i'm going to make this janky on purpose
but the personality in yours is is
it's got a lot unmatched it's got to be
like buschemied out
you know
[Laughter]
absolutely we have a minute and 51
seconds peter
all right i'm going for uh materials now
materials
these are materials
just gonna add a little sub surf
a little make it a little shiny actually
rough and then a clear coat
actually no it looks crappy yeah there
we go
what the i'm gonna plug a little noise
texture
into a bumper y'all see there's hope you
know if you're like me
like there's hope knowing that you can
get better
you know um how do i make this better as
quick as possible
um how about
that looks so funny
uh loki i'm i'm i'm jealous
that's hilarious i wish i made that i'm
loving this dude this is a good time
peter i'm glad i'm glad we're doing this
together
oh yeah yeah thanks for inviting me i'm
happy to be 45 seconds
cool
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yours looks so good you just looks like
a freaking beeple render dude
i think he has i think he has like a
rubber duck he's like a desert or
something
i forget which one uh yeah i think
you're right
all right dude that's time no dude times
last time dude it's over man
what is that an ocean you light peter
mine look okay look so mine mine looks
like a cankle but then
if you actually look if you actually
look at it correctly
it's a duck and it's and it's a duck
that's had better
better days
the duck that waddled out into the road
at a very poor time
yours looks so good dude that's
that's awesome thank you thanks i
appreciate that man
that's sick you like you had time for
materials man what the heck
um all right yo let me see that butt let
me see that butt though
see that butt no no but i don't want to
show the butt it's my least i'm the
least proud of them
too good dude i don't know about this
anymore i know
yeah it's it's a little square it's like
a lizard tail that got chopped off great
okay so what was your technique on this
what'd you do
on this i started with the sphere and
then i just extruded it out a little bit
and
yeah it just starting with the general
shape already is
makes it much easier so i basically just
started with that and then i would take
like a little piece and just extrude it
and move it just like following the
general shape
and then once i had that i took the
whole thing and i just like
used proportional editing to um
you know grab a little piece and just
shift it back yeah so that would be like
soft selection
in c4 and just
yeah yeah and then just grab this stuff
and extrude it a little bit
that's great so it's all about like
knowing how
like you went with that approach and
that worked out way better
than my freaking box head
looking duck this thing is changing oh
the wrong how did you go i mean
i don't know about the wrong way it just
means a lot more love
um but what did you do
with the cube how'd um which may have
been my first mistake and then
i extruded to basically get a low poly
version of this thing
and then i threw it into a subdivision
surface
um and i like just kind of chopped it up
a little bit try to get that low poly
um yeah and then i just did a plane here
for the bill that i just same deal you
know
start with a plane extruded it out yeah
um
threw it into a subdivision surface and
then my eyeballs are just stretched and
squashed
spheres yeah same
i love your character that's great dude
good times
let's check out everyone else's let's
see what they got
yeah yeah all right
oh damn oh there's some good ones oh
there's some janky ones too
everyone had time for their textures
that's great
wow oh wow gub
there's so many dude there's so many oh
my there's some cursed ones
holy [ __ ] jacob i have to get to the top
first
oh my god i know there's so many
okay okay okay okay here we go here we
go
dude yeah okay herman's good stuff
uh deadly laser good stuff i like the
minecraft
yeah i love the little good stuff um
sriga was
[Laughter]
uh monkey oh my god pork what the heck
this is like jacked that's so creepy
that's incredible uh ask is good with
like i like how you're including them
all
yeah more low poly i love the shade yeah
yeah
um i'm just scrolling down there's a lot
here um
the notable standout ones jaylen kind of
cursed a little bit
i like it um
uh pillow ford oh it knows
it is a there's a duck and it is a good
school
um slowly
like it just got squashed yeah it looks
like a pokemon uh
dude has azubius
so angry jacobster wow
that's really good yeah that's really
great damn
damn even got the
is that a model they downloaded because
that's really good for
it is really good yeah the time we had
that's amazing if they if you model that
that's incredible
um what else uh lowly wizard is pretty
good
that's that's that's fun um
lots of really good ones yeah pickle
juice yours kind of looks like that frog
a little bit dude
as homer simpson as a duck
[Laughter]
oak tree is like i feel like this very
memeable duck it's like me when i
when yeah it's great oh let's let's try
and find the most oh wow big mac holy
crap that's really good
let's try and find the most cursed one
oh okay
oh my god there's literally a homer
simpson the one above immortal pickles
is pretty cursed
under here that one is pretty damn
cursed it's like
hey what else do we oh my god mr v vky
looks it almost looks like a person
oh my god that one is up there for most
cursed spoilers
okay let's see what else we got oh nice
got the shades
default animator dude blue twist
do you see the drawing
oh my god that's amazing i was just
looking at
mn78 above the drawing yeah it uh
it looks like that duck put on lipsticks
like it's seen things dude
it's seeing things
um there's a lot here there's a lot
of extreme derpy is pretty good
echa gold i like your your animated
drawings these are really good
i'm digging these animated drawings
see
yeah these are all solid um
yeah great job everybody brad brad
you'll know the teeth dude
i lost track i can't see what you're
doing
evolver i thought he had work to do man
he's making ducks
oh you know that is a beautiful sketch
very talented
sketchy i'm trying to catch up with you
trying to sync up here
oh oh i thought it was before you
see i'm just going through there's so
many
these are all really good guys everyone
has really
captured the essence of the duck
oh nice you got a wide duck i like that
so fun seeing all the personality and
all of these zeb chan really good stuff
here
like that ben good drawing man
freeze 3d has the cat and the duck
together i like it
oh you were past me evolver yeah with
his with his scene
so those are assets i know you working
you don't got time for that
you got assets pulled up ready to go
that's great
these are solid a no with the drawing
black and white drawing is super solid
shadow dwarf with the teeth digging it
ah look at this we got some really cool
drawing everyone's doing such a good job
i'm really proud of you guys thank you
for uh
for putting in the effort and doing this
with us this is really cool
we got 2 400 people in the chat going
strong good stuff
and bogdy with that sketch that's
incredible crawlworth
i like it like the ms paint it's
stylized i dig it
really cool
ed l good stuff
latchy yes a little cursed wow there's
like
uh otto doing the angry bird that's
really well sculpted
very good everybody ooh
magic of vauxhall dr very good
that's really cool uh snowy that that's
awesome
so many ducks
oh wow virtual that's really good it's
oh my god we're not even halfway through
uh gub gub wobbler your drawings are
really good man
i dig those so much derek thank you for
the super chat brother
appreciate you man finland nice
photoshop there
oh 3da au that lighting dude
it's almost like a pirate duck i love it
wow at the end so many good ones
wow bogdy
that drawing jeez that's so good
that's so good just using like there was
no lines
it was just filling in shadow and light
that's so good
i'm always so impressed with 2d art
because like
i feel like with me i i let the computer
do so much of the work it's like i just
get it halfway there and the computer's
like i got you
but with 2d it's like you have to have
the whole thing in your head
before you start it's so impressive yeah
drawing drawing is really fun
it it you're a student
um holy crap the angry duck whoa
it's so angry yeah wow
yeah it's very similar though like it
starts with a sketch and it goes from
there
um dang these are all really good guys
good there's so many wow rose
rosu that's amazing
the drawing ones are really cool
man all right we gotta we gotta move on
to the next ten minute one here
i'll scroll down as much as i'm alright
again
these are awesome piece of pizza
it's right in your face i love it that's
good man good stuff
i'll at least get to the end you know
we'll get everyone's everyone's ducks in
here
people making movies holy crap
oh that's cool i'll dig that
i like the low poly ones too oregon
so many ducks
that's it all right so peter we are on
to
our fourth round four out of six rounds
this is our last 10 minute round
and then we'll move on to the 30 minute
ones um vincent thank you for the super
chat all right greetings from ireland
um i love ireland been there last year
the year before for my birthday
good stuff oh god that's so good i want
to go man looks beautiful
it's a beautiful place um okay so let's
switch over
we're going to pop this off
um 2 400 people up in the chat thank you
guys for joining us
um hopefully y'all are learning
something as we do this
because i know i am this is fun
okay um
yeah all right here we go um this is our
round four our last 10 minute round
so to monte let me reset the timer
and hit it
the eiffel tower wow
kind of hard to see from that tiny view
there
but i'll do my
best i'm going to pull up a reference
image for myself
yeah yeah i know that really is that
within the rules
what i go about this best suited
damn this is a tough one good suggestion
i guess we can start with like face
shape
god bless you
just gonna start with the grid and uh
remove everything but the four corners
and then start extruding those up
y'all yeah
that
something like that and i'm going to
merge overlapping vertices so these are
all connected
and then
here
hard to tell based off of this
but it tiny like there's something like
this
up in there
definitely suggest uh looking it up on
google images because
that's been helping me a lot
having good references you can't beat it
wow this thing is advanced um it can be
advanced
[Music]
um
i meet like half ways
that with is maintain
basically throughout that
i think you you had it you were doing
what i'm doing now but you just did it
faster
oh nice yeah i just
i don't know i just started with the
four corners and like connected them at
the top
and then i'm doing like i'm just trying
to get the shape right here
doing this such as so slowly six minutes
holy crap
six minutes damn it
wow okay brute force
okay um
okay okay okay you know what i'm going
to do i'm going to
triangulate it no sub attacks in
geometry
can triangulate it i'm going to throw a
wireframe modifier on it
i'm doing i i waste so much time yeah
oh no
wow that's bad see if i can recover
and we upload this to turbo squid that's
the thing that's
that's what it
i have is upload it to turbo squid and
submit it by the time the timer's out
i'm gonna make these little platforms
wow dude are you serious are you serious
you serious what am i doing over here
what am i doing
wow gotta throw that wire frame on there
son
oh my god dude i just want to quit now
we have four minutes
uh i shouldn't have left don't even say
that dude
don't even the whole chat is gonna
explode
um wow what am i doing
this is rough
use a circle and like roughly line it up
to the edge
uh three minutes
okay we got this okay let's see
i don't even know how you did that like
i have to subdivide this like crazy and
do like trying
out the triangulated thing
yeah that's exactly what i did
yeah i like triangulate it and then
threw a wire frame
modifier on there
minute 50 time flies
seriously dude okay that's good enough
i duplicate
honestly like
real i've seen the modeling tools in
c4d and i think blender is like
easier i would probably agree with that
oh thank god
oh no
55 seconds
no 55 seconds
okay
if c searches anything
awesome mw
oh i'm just just ranting
shift c will search anything in c4d and
then
i need to get the top piece 28 seconds
i missed the arch dude maybe i can get
the arch real
quick i oh yeah you
17 seconds dude
material material there's no freaking
way
dude yeah i'm i'm not
wow didn't have time for that you guys
did that
dude that's that's time that's time
wow all right no no yours looks good
enough
yours is good enough
there we go oh my goodness
yeah all right let me see yours let me
see yours go full frame on that
dude
good stuff man
it's this is such a hard thing to model
also i'm realizing my proportions a
little bit
a little bit it's a little squashy again
man
that was tough that was super tough yeah
i feel like
just the the um like the top third of
yours needs to be tapered a little bit
more
yeah i'm totally right i need the arch
you got the arch on the bottom
down for sure i need to get that um but
i think
if you ask people like what is this
most people would be like oh yeah
the eiffel tower and yes mine does look
like a telecommunications tower i agree
you are not wrong okay um but like
it still looks like the eiffel tower
though like you got the shape down and
you got the like the uh
wireframe yes thank goodness thank
goodness i got the wireframe that was
what did it um
it's the arch i needed the arch i think
that would have
that would have done it for me yeah um
dude my arch is so janky it's literally
a circle mesh that i extruded upwards
and then just like went like
with it and then subdivided it along the
way it's better than not having an arch
that's the difference between
delivering the vibe and not delivering
the vibe because
that's the biggest thing someone said
mine mine looks like a
telecommunications arch and that
or um tower right that's that's a
negative
those are like i didn't win in that case
because someone someone thought it was
something else
but with yours you know what that is
right you know i wonder if it's the uh
the arch that helps make it feel like
that let me like let me take this out
and let's see if it still feels like the
eiffel tower
yeah see it definitely looks more like a
just a radio tower
um i think though
for yours having that tapered butt
it look it looks like the eiffel tower
more so than mine because mine is like
not as tapered
um i see i see yeah
so here's the question though is this
the vegas version or the paris version
that's the question that's a good
question let's take a look at everyone
else's let's see what uh
[ __ ] let's see what we got yeah yeah
yeah
damn
i just like found one that looked
amazing there's no way they modeled that
in this time
render warrior that's ridiculous
that's just a photo let's go to the very
tippy
top all right sweet um
damn nice there's some good ones here
oh sloth dev that's good i like that
got some drawings very cool very cool
and animated with arms and legs
abstract games i like your audition here
very nice
yeah this is a tough one 10 min in 10
minutes is very difficult
yeah a lot of these are just flat it
looks like you guys are just doing like
one
one chunk of it um
yeah this is tough reference is the key
on this
one very specific shape definitely
good work everybody
oh yeah seriously well like the curve
you want dave has a good
perspective drawing they did yeah
great perspective oh wait a wild guy i
see what you're saying
[Music]
nice ar
hsm i say your biggest your biggest
thing here is uh reference just try and
use that reference
for perspective and proportion i think
that'd be the main note for everybody is
um
reference yeah use the reference as much
as possible
also just like if there's any way to
bring the image into your 3d software
just like using it as a background is
always so helpful i always do that for
like
yeah absolutely absolutely
uh nubu very good very good drawing
there
yeah ronin's good ronin is one of our
mods he's up in the chat right now i
think he's
moderating oh hell yeah
honeycomb tower wow
mdk definitely that's like a great he's
another mod too
yeah um yeah totally oh no way
it's very good it's fantastic yeah it
reads very well modeled
oh that like curvy wick like fire
one oh the snow yeah that's great
that's great
quantum that's not bad i know that's
good too
you know with those sketches damn
jonas
reference reference reference jarvis is
like i don't know what i made
get that reference
i someone made a hard tower
oh augustia
that's really good really good
can i issue a challenge to our viewers
i would love if anybody you know has
some time and wants a little project to
uh
i would love to see like combining
all of these things that we're making
into like a scene that makes sense
contextually you mean like
you know all the power or you say
take these five models yeah like taking
the
take your duck take your cat and your
eiffel tower
and whatever else we make and like put
it in the same scene and like
try to tell a story with it yeah that
could be cool maybe maybe
the next challenge here the weekly
challenge
oh oh yeah you do challenges that's fine
about that um
yeah you have to like use all the models
in a unique way to tell a story
okay yeah i like that could be cool um
all right back to the discord
we'll take a look at a few more of these
and then we'll hop back into
round five out of six that we'll do
and this will be two 30 minute rounds
so we will really have to work in the
detail of these next two rounds
yeah these are all ready these are all
pretty darn good
um this one was significantly more
difficult
yeah definitely a lot of detail which is
exactly you know hard to get
a lot of people went for just like
switched up the style to like a low poly
or
like game asset style and that
definitely echo gold again with
solid cartoony drawings really good
muggy sleet that's gotta be an asset
that's really good there's no way 10
minutes
like freaking nuts
um some really good drawings everybody
really impressed oh wow
ah adam that's cool
very nice very nice i dig it ben
good stuff oscar i really like how
you're putting all the drawings into one
oak tree good good job on the top down
perspective
i'm really digging these drawings
sweet good stuff everybody
oh yeah wow that's great
nice i don't know if that was modeled in
10 minutes but good job i'm assuming
y'all are being honest with this
challenging yourself
render warrior if that there's no way
there's just no way there's no way on
some of these
oh i think render warrior is a photo
i could be wrong though
this is good stuff yeah i like all this
everything lined up
random out of context pictures
evolver thanks for the super chat man he
says he loves the format he stopped
working
to watch and join so that's chill man
heck yeah
sweet hell yeah that's everything so
peter
um we're on to our fifth round this is
gonna be a 30 minute round we're taking
your suggestions
uh sodamonte probably has something
already queued up hell yeah
um yeah me too this will be one where
we'll actually have time to add detail
so
um i'm excited for this one it's going
to be good
and after these two rounds of 30 minute
uh submissions or 30 minute prompts then
uh peter is going to bounce and then
i'll do the weekly challenge i'll go
over some of the weekly challenge art
um and then yeah
gonna be a good time so let's hop into
it let's hop into
the third one here let's switch over to
our working scene
and let me queue up a
30 minute timer here briefly bear with
me all
right
somebody's using if uh somebody's asking
if we can use online
i mean sure yeah it's a modeling
challenge you know so like yeah
texturing is cherry on top
okay peter are you ready
born ready definitely you have to use
the restaurant next one
yeah let's let's take a two minute break
i'll be back yeah yeah sounds good i'll
be back two minutes or so
see you guys soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all yo yo the hair's a
little crazy you know but whatever
whatever it's all good um so i'm waiting
on peter he'll probably be back in like
two seconds
um but thank you guys for joining us
this is
really exciting really fun i think this
could be a thing this could work here
um it'd be fun to do this maybe once a
month we can do texture challenges we
can do simulation challenges
whatever i think it could be really sick
um peter euback
i hear movement
soon soon if you guys have any questions
i'm down to answer any questions while
peter makes some coffee
and we'll hop into our last two rounds
30 minutes each
appreciate y'all for the super chats and
the support very very cool
um yeah i'm really i'm really excited
we're gonna be
i'm gonna be making a patreon uh this
month
probably do an announcement video later
this month and
it's gonna be really sweet it's gonna be
an awesome chance for you guys to uh
connect a little bit more to get some
stuff for free well not for free but
just
it'll you know you know how patreon
works it's a monthly thing but um
i'm gonna have all my assets packs uh
project files
everything uh behind the scenes stuff
art review
uh streams it'll be a lot of cool stuff
um
that i'm excited to announce so coming
soon
very very soon y'all um
so any questions y'all y'all might have
thoughts on peter's stash i love the
fact that he's rocking it
guys he's rocking that stash do i ever
do sculpting i do not no
um let's see
when's the next community challenge oh
that's a good question i'm actually
announcing the next
big community challenge um next week
so next week will be the big one we're
doing things a little bit different
um as in the prompt will be different
it's gonna be
really cool and i'm so excited to piece
them all together to form
something that i'll announce uh next
week
so definitely keep your eyes peeled for
that it's gonna be sweet i'm gonna
challenge you guys over the next month
um to do something cool so yeah it'll be
good
yo sun get that coffee
oh yeah i need it a little sleepy
all right i'm feeling refreshed you
feeling good peter
doing great all right round five of six
we got 30 minutes on this one we don't
know what we're gonna model
yet this is from your suggestion
uh through discord um we're going to do
one more suggestion if you want to guys
if you guys want to get your suggestions
in there's a link attached to
the live chat here go on over
post a picture in a text description and
sotomonte
the moderator working behind the scenes
right now he's going to pull it and
present it to us
so that's exactly what we did he did
here for round five
uh sodamonte let's go for it man what
you got
what is that
what is that is that a pokemon
i i think it's a like a an aquatic
creature
the lizard type thing i don't know
whoa okay all i know is that they just
added them to minecraft
okay so cute oh my god
i love this little guy
how am i gonna do this all right
i think i'm gonna follow your rubber
duck situation
solid there we go
so we have uh 30 minutes yeah all right
sounds good
what a crazy looking creature
oh i believe there are things like that
that exist that's just amazing yeah
it's this totally like just a pokemon
yeah so when's the last time you've been
to the aquarium
i actually went a few months ago i went
to the san francisco uh
like pier aquarium which was okay it's
not the best aquarium but it was fun and
i got to see
cute little fishies and some sharks and
stuff was great that's cool
yeah i'm a fan we went to the long beach
aquarium probably like
uh i don't know maybe like two months
ago
i'm a big fan of like the penguins and
stuff
the birds yeah penguins are my are my
absolute favorite
penguins are super cute they really are
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna grab a little
reference image here
let's drag that right on blender
this is very similar to like that
raindrop thing you did
i feel like oh yeah
little dude
um
alright
um
smart what you're doing peter
smart what you're doing
what am i doing yeah what you're doing
is smart
like the way you're modeling it yeah
dude modeling off of pictures is always
so much easier
get some symmetry up in here no one has
time for that
i'm gonna turn on screencast keys so you
guys can see what i'm doing
uh is that a blender like option
it's a little plug on a plug on it's a
plugin where it says on the screen what
keys are being pressed
you may not be able actually yeah you
can see it kind of just above your head
there okay half and half of it
i might be able to move it actually yeah
why don't you work on that yeah
i'll work on the model
that visible
this is like there we go the last thing
i do is model this kind of stuff
it's it's so not what i do
yeah i feel a little lucky because i
model stuff like this all the time i'm
gonna get that
so crazy
it's little face dude it's so cute
i know i love it
it's insane that that's a real thing
i know dude world's an amazing place
i wonder if i can actually make this
part of
um
hill kind of like a long tail
and it tapers it's a weird tapering
situation
i think my biggest issue is i just don't
have the workflow down
for stuff like this
yeah i've been doing like character
modeling for a long time and
i've the best way i've realized for me
is just like starting with some kind of
uh
rectangular or like slightly circular
shape and then going like
lengthwise extruding outward and then
you just take some of those faces
and you just like extrude them out with
the limbs
ooh such an interesting
actually yeah having references helping
someone just kind of just
taper down
it like starts all spindly
look
such a strange shape
um it goes from like a a tube horizontal
to a
flat tube article i have to
you're right in between that
whoa coco
i'm gonna start extruding some limbs
here
actually i'm gonna turn on my mirror
modifier so i only have to do this once
yeah there you go
cute little bud we got 20 minutes
sweet i'm flies dude during these things
honestly
it's crazy
[Music]
wow
it has this like spine
right yeah kind of like a weird
translucent type thing
and then like the fin
piece like tapers you know like
on the top and bottom tapers to a real
like
thin translucent piece
kind of happy with that
um
wait
let's get some thingies
ah it's better than nothing all right
his fingers
definitely taper like super hard
dude i feel like tapering is the word of
the day it's a good one dude
uh my gizmo is all jacked
what's wrong with it just not aligned
best way to do this
a bevel situation
yeah that kind of works
gross
hello
hmm
wait peter didn't you two like you had
like a pack of like
did you model i remember one time at
corridor you were i was like sitting
next to you
and you were working with like a frog
and then you had like a bird
scene in the forest and stuff were those
modeled by you oh yeah those are those a
pack
no that was a pack from uh blender
market there's like a pack of 250
uh low poly animals that's that's great
i love just opening that up and making
shitty little scenes with it it looks so
good yeah your
your animal stuff looks really great
nice dude okay i feel like i put the arm
love i love creature stuff it's always
fun
i need to detach this arm and move it
down to another
section
it's on yeah i'm not not upset
yet yes
oh i got them
we got 11 minutes left
i have to move on to the face
and and the gills i forgot about the
freaking face
and the gills damn it and it has feet
too are you kidding me i'll just copy
these guys
let me copy this really quick
guys so cute what the heck
i know i want to be the friend
he's got little feet he's popping off
dude my stomach is growling all right
what's that head look like
a little schnecky
how you feeling about yours
i'm digging mine i'm happy with it
that's great that's great
all right it's time it's time to
ruin it with the face here
has these beady little eyes
yeah they're cute
i think the key here is symmetry
totally yeah it's definitely not worth
doing something more than once
oh wow that is horrible
little mouth dude so cute
so cute it's the fact that the eyes this
is a great suggestion yeah
yeah whoever suggested this kudos
a great
i'm not i'm not too upset about this
we have six minutes boy all right
shoot oh
can i just have like a month to work on
this seriously man
uh okay material time
i'm not even i'm not even messing with
materials
that's not bad it's not bad okay
down
okay here goes
i'm doing this in like the worst way
i literally did the exact same thing
just janking it into place
yeah pretty much
there's a varinoi texture inverted
to get kind of a scaly look
unwrap
well that doesn't look good four minutes
that looks great man wow that's cool
all right the gills interesting okay
oh [ __ ] there are gills aren't they
okay
so
looks so weird how did i [ __ ] this up
what the [ __ ]
clint what's the vibe with uh cursing on
your stream i mean i don't
but you know me i i just don't anyway um
yeah sorry it's just been slipping out i
mean there's some kids up in here
so i'll keep it
chill sometimes sometimes it
comes out you know i do
there we go
there we go now we're talking
uh two minutes
cool
laughs
wait
i think overall let's see we got a
minute left
make sure you guys post your submissions
we can take a look at them
what else we got here oh [ __ ]
all right 20 seconds what about the done
top part shoot how part what top part
a little of the spine yeah
okay 20 seconds all right i can do that
kind of goes up
six seconds
i think that's time
that's good enough all right dude yours
looks so good
thanks man all right
yeah you got it up in the forest there
oh yeah wait very cool
i wish i had more time for materials you
even got the
hair fluff on the on the like little
antenna things too
yeah he has weird little like tendrils
coming off of the
antenna you said there were gills where
are the gills are they like under the
i kept saying gills i meant the antennas
with the with like the
oh on them yeah
yeah who knows what i'm saying dude
yours is freaking cute yeah this guy
look at this freaking guy
he's ready for a good time i want to
hang out that little guy yeah i
i'm for me i'm happy with this man like
this is the last thing i model
but i got the tail like tapered at the
top and bottom it actually looks like it
has some like
depth to it or some thickness to it um
and then
yeah the spine piece that comes up and
the arms and stuff and
probably could have greased out a little
bit more tapered it a little bit more
but yeah i was happy with how this
turned out um it could be a lot cleaner
oh yeah but yeah you know
always stuff we can improve on but looks
great yeah dude
um that was awesome that was really good
to work on um that was fun see i'm gonna
scrub through the chat here real quick
but what on earth random diagnostics
whoa oh my god these are awesome holy
[ __ ] yeah let's see
let's see what you guys got oh my god
these are incredible
going to the top here wow so many people
gave it a shot yeah i'm still getting up
to the top oh there's a low poly one
the minecraft axolotl
that's so good squidgy i love the low
poly version man
it's like so satisfying oh that's
that's from minecraft oh is it oh it's
just a freaking picture they posted
yeah dang that troll i mean but they
said it's from the minecraft
i got double troll they could have read
this somebody just has
that's crazy an iguana or something my
uh my science teacher used to have one
they're so cool
yeah they're the best oh no this one got
chopped horrible
oh my just drawing that's sick
that's really good yeah
this is a pokemon like how is this just
not a pokemon
honestly it's like a real-life pokemon
lots of drawings this time around uh
yeah i love the drawing x-ray
good attempt man good stuff like it it
looks like i think it's just the
textures you know
oh my god oh my god papa bless that's
terrifying
so cursed
good stuff larry
hey finn uh finji boy i like that
i like that a lot it's cute
oh we got some hair on and i know it's
like half cursed it has a vein look at
that vein on the side
oh six that's intense
whoa that's yeah that's super cool
interesting style
you didn't got the ribs in that's cool
nubu
really good stuff good drawing
yeah that's like wish dragon i love the
the blocky
yeah it looks like a wish dragon or
something mr handsome
the low poly but who knows maybe that's
a troll
oh my god manny 1000.
oh man that's great
whoa what happened to reigns it looked
like a mouse
the side what happened on the side
little spider legs
roman with the subsurface a little bit
i nice is my favorite yeah it's just
like a little like
little pod
whoa this like buff axle yeah
cool
um zergs isn't bad
oh yeah bubblegum
love that subserve whoa cool sculpt by
jtx2 that's animated that's cool yeah
that's a good one
love the low poly tumi
oh somebody made the minecraft version
yeah that's really oh my god
yeah mr vky is hilarious
so good it's like a bubblegum monster
nomo what's up awesome
crystal pics
that's good
love that one
whoa um i aino's looks like a
uh what is it called what's that pokemon
dragonair dragonite that drawing
whoa i love blue twist yeah that's a
beautiful art style it's like just dots
that's blue twist i want to put that up
in my house that's
awesome super cool
whoa bronze is really good
oh yeah that's great yeah you can
definitely tell when people use
reference images yeah
that helps the animated gif
is so good yes
yes oh panda
oh my goodness yeah amazing
that's really good that's such an
interesting style
that's awesome ah block master i love me
some 8-bit art
so much
oh that's really nice cave dave great
color palette look at that
whoa that's whoa it's like translucent
let's see we'll screen it you can see
there's a diver in the middle
whoa that's really cool oh
eggy64
that's cool whoa
that's dope
more minecraft dig it
what the heck dude
wow that is amazing
jeez it's all about the uh
the white the highlighter pencil over
top
for sure totally yeah it uh in
in the tail it adds the feeling of like
i don't know that translucent material
like bone poking through
that's so good and they use the paper as
the mid-tone
that's amazing yeah that's brilliant
that's really cool
these are tough creatures andre good
stuff wow
andres yeah z brush it look oh no that's
blender yeah that's sick
oh yeah it's like a skipping stone
i love the 8-bit so much
chrysler in the business suit
going to work mitch mitch that's pretty
good
oh that's dope
i'm so proud of you guys so many so many
submissions for this that's awesome
honestly y'all are killing it
wow really good stuff
nobody lemon oh what happened where did
i skip it
it's just really cute oh yeah
that's good that's really good
kendov kendov is really nice mm-hmm
solid i like the uh the
like crease yeah that's really nice
whoa
there's some good ones and henriques
looks like a vacuum cleaner
like those hand vacuum cleaners
that's great
i love it
heck eka gold good stuff
whoa braum gee
doing the uh bang
uh camera mapping or cam what is it
called yeah doing that
ian hubert yeah style
projection projection mapping yeah
sweet oscar looking good lots of good
drawings there
this is great dude oh my god brad bread
awesome
this freaking beefed out version
it's a green beefed out version
whoa
well there's a video uh by woozy face
and it's animated it's pretty sweet
that's super sick damn otto what the
heck
what the heck dude freaking otto needs
to be in the stream not me that's
it's really good that's really good
yeah these are so good guys i love the
minecraft ones i know me too
so good so
look at this drawing by freak joker it's
all the things combined like you said
oh shoot let me find that that's crazy
oh my god yeah
that's amazing yes i love it
blender bb that's pretty good
like dancing one
[Laughter]
that's so funny there's such a random
text
what i love it's so makes it
i'm saving that
oh twisted verve the face on that is
pretty cursed that's great
oh man
whoa aldo yeah yeah that one's really
good
that's really cool i love how synced up
here too
yeah yeah i've been trying to follow
along
um i love uh when people like
put their own style into it it's really
cool seeing that
agreed
oh last prince that's cool with like the
gelatin green on the tail
and then the one right below that on
oval
sand oval pretty sweet
yeah let's do it
jack the hack good stuff man you do good
work
pretty solid
ah death wings it's it's stylized man
it's not the worst it's just stylized
and nest gg that was good man
yeah i like that blender yeah it's
always really smart doing a lot with a
little yeah yeah exactly
the blender crash that's hilarious
wait yeah it looks like some reposts
um scrubbing down here
what the heck scotty i love the low poly
game asset version
whoa scotty's is great it's the one with
like depth of field
with like the bluish background that's
insane
that's insane it's like it almost looks
photoreal
[Laughter]
oh wow yeah scotty that looks great yeah
what virtual oh my goodness
that is ridiculous sculpted to
perfection
wow
that's so good geez oh my god yeah
yeah sculpting is something i really
want to get into yeah it's the way to go
for this
eugene dude scroll down until you're
just like oh my god
this perfect zbrush
i know yeah that's so good
wow he textured it that's good oh
wow that looks amazing
lighting solid all right switching back
yeah that was great everybody yeah these
are
super cool very impressive oh oh my uh
my camera's frozen for some reason give
me
one second here
bam all right we should be good um
so we have one more 30 minute round to
go
um thank you guys for sticking with us
and making cool stuff um doing this
together with you guys
is so cool that's like the way to do it
um
oh yeah it's super fun yeah yeah
uh evolver thank you for the super chat
and everyone else who's been super
chatting i really appreciate you guys
the support really helps out um
and it helps me do this full time you
know you guys know i'm doing this full
time now so
it really really helps out so thank you
guys
and uh yeah i'm excited to get into our
last round here peter are you uh
feeling good
i'm feeling great man i'm having a great
time to do some more modeling
let's do it i'm feeling good yeah i'm
feeling really good i
wasn't too bummed about uh about that
last one
my eiffel tower pretty bummed not gonna
lie but uh
yeah yeah modeling is difficult
modeling is very difficult yeah um
so all right so dimonte thank you uh
he's the moderator behind the scenes
dropping these challenges on us we're
not seeing them
until he drops them so it's for the very
first time
let's switch over um all right
yeah he's great he's amazing um super
helpful
such a good mod um tapioca
senpai thank you um boba teacher
boba sensei thank you for the super chat
that's great
um okay y'all let me reset this timer
and we're gonna do this we got 30
minutes
final round and then i'm gonna get into
reviewing
the weekly challenge and i'll announce
the five winners
and uh we'll announce the new challenge
which might be combining all five
of these models into
heck yeah i i don't want to uh uh
commandeer your challenge if you already
had something planned out i don't
know we can hear about how about we do
it as an option
i'll do a poll and then i'll have that
as one of the options there you go there
you go yeah um
sweet all right this is the final round
round six thanks for hanging out with us
um let's do some cool stuff here um
oh yeah all right so damonte are
you ready
hit it
oh heck yeah old camera let's go okay
let's go all right that's a medium
format
film camera or large format let's see uh
dm format old film camera
uh large format i'll just type old film
trying to find the right reference it
looks like uh like
is it is it a still though it's a still
camera
old large format camera uh
yeah old large format still camera
i'll pick something that's generally
close yeah here we go
oh a vintage large format i'm fine with
this
sweet okay let's knock this out
anybody in the chat know uh what the
actual like name of this camera is
i just typed in vintage large format
film camera and like
there's a there's a lot of good ones
yeah i just uh
i want to find uh like the same thing
from like
the top and the side or the schematics
yeah let's do this
with we got the back piece
i'm gonna block it out first then we'll
go in
for special and stenograph
oh hell yeah it's called the special
instantograph patent camera
thank you that's that's a mouthful
okay great
this is a cool piece of technology here
okay question for you clint is f spy
allowed or are we modeling hands off um
you know what i'm not going to use f
spot that's cheating fair
fair
all right here we go here we go 17
i'm just going off i from this one here
that's probably a good idea
so one thing that helps me work faster
is uh
to hold control and spawn primitives
on current objects that i already have
in my scene
by holding ctrl they spawn in that area
already though
helps me out a lot is there anything
like that in blender
um yeah you just have like a 3d cursor
that you can like shift right click and
place anywhere and then
wherever that cursor is you'll like
spawn an object
yeah it's pretty useful
it looks like it slides in and out
oh yeah that's really cool this is a
really interesting
yeah it's fun to like figure out how
something works
based off of like you know when you're
modeling it it's pretty pretty sweet
yeah totally
all right the most helpful things i
learned from modeling
from my blender peeps is inset
if you have a face and you press i it'll
create a face and scale it proportional
to the face that you
originally selected and then you can
like extrude outward
or inward super useful
this is so much fun this is like this is
what i really enjoy doing oh yeah
reuse this drag it over here
let's get along the axis
technically i guess this is as long as
this is technically like a little panel
here that will open up
yeah that's i'd buy that
i'm gonna cut out it looks like
all right
bevels here
here 3 and 1.5
oh [ __ ]
no my undo isn't working
you need to restart shoot all right it's
fine
no no no i think just the like
you undo q got messed up you know
quick enough
beat ain't got that section
probably could have done that a little
better but
a bit more efficient
mb is your bridge tool
i can throw a bevel deformer in here
holding shift
will make an automatic child of whatever
you have selected
oh boy let's optimize it
grab all those points ctrl a hit uo for
optimize and maybe that'll take care of
it no
what's going on
wow what am i doing
this is tough so weird why is that
doing that
okay i guess it's just one double point
whatever
peter do you own any cameras like this
no i freaking wish uh you're into still
like uh film style um yeah
yeah it's awesome i've always wanted
it's really cool
to like see your art you know come out
on to a physical
you know printed thing and physical
strips
i've never done anything like this
though this is next level
like this just kind of goes back into
here slides in there
oops
um
i'll throw that bevel modifier in there
hold shift
it's already doing its thing
all right let's get this lens down
so this is just extrude enter and
extrude that's about
it the whole way through so
grab these points ul
and
mw as extrude enter
and d is extrude
w extrude enter
extrude
looks like go move these four
and this kind of insets i'll go in a
little bit back
extra dinner a little bit more and then
out so
there's just like a little gap in there
and based off my reference i can't
really see
what's going on but i'll just start
making stuff up at this
yeah i feel ya i know it comes out
out again
and i started seeing stuff again let's
go extrude enter
a little bit
i'll save that
inner all the way
i'll make some cuts hey l
boom
extrude
same for here i think there's like a
little piece here
a little tiny piece right in there
hey
all right more detail let's see um the
lens is looking fine if it
had to end here we got 15 minutes left
peter
oh boy all right i guess i should start
on this like uh
like the biggest thing i'm missing right
now is that like scrunchy leather
uh light enclosure yeah dude it's such a
weird shape i really
was having a hard time wrapping my head
around it so i ended up just doing
accordion
that's basically what it is
um i think it starts
right up here it kind of works its way
back
and this is what basically will trap the
light
film camera so let's get that going
yet
hey maybe
make some room for this thing so
grab these up extrude
it's here
something like that
make some little knobs to throw around
various parts
hey accordion situation
double cuts down this thing
um
okay so every other one on the top
and bottom it pushed
up this
and every other one on the sides
it's scrunched in
something like that
feels about right
oh nice oh you figured it out
yeah they go opposite i think i think
you have it
you haven't got your gotcha no it's just
uh
mine's like too even i think
they're all going the same way
yeah you got it damn
and then they kind of like scrunch
towards the back a little bit
probably have a couple more pieces but i
think it's fine
let's not do that let's just do a bevel
fire on that
so large with it like three centimeters
and
pieces the creases i feel like would be
like a bump map or something
totally
we've got ten minutes i guess you could
all right all right let's make a knob
i'm feeling about yours
what about you nice
yeah i'm definitely struggling more with
this one but i don't feel too bad about
it it's looking good
thanks all right so i'll make a couple
knobs that i can duplicate
um let's yeah
probably could have just done this from
a disk but whatever um
make it editable we'll scrunch it down
grab these middle points here
control shift z will undo camera moves
bring that down
and i'll be lazy with this
like a cylinder
basically that will be my knob very
quick
get this gizmo down towards the bottom
hit an l bam
i can
duplicate this all around
holding shift to snap to certain angles
every five degrees like this comes right
up in here and it's used to tighten it
close this back piece i'm also going to
take this
cylinder and let's double these edges
too
so bam bam ms
a little bit
always bevel them edges
oh yeah i haven't been doing that
oh [ __ ] we'll drag
um guys
over
whole thing
we got six and a half minutes roughly
yeah all right feeling it
this piece needs work um
okay see let's get
get this piece going we'll need
um let's just get that face right here
and i'll make some cuts in this
um
bam
down the middle i'll delete these
two and
subdivision surface
kind of the wrong way to cut a hole out
of this but fine
four minutes
alrighty not too bad
yeah i'm feeling the same feeling pretty
good
give this the old control a
some caps popping off
three minutes
sweet sweet
i do this in three minutes um
come this mn we'll get rid of those
want to add
what do we do with our minute
you left on some quick materials or uh
do what you got
um and then i just need to cut some
holes out oh my god
oh it was almost the end
oh [ __ ]
if this works
in a 10.
i guess that works i guess that works
for now
sure
let's go let's go
oh no i have to duplicate this
let's get it over here
180
two sec last time
oh yeah yeah all right oh wow peter that
looks so good
what the heck thanks man oh damn dude
yours looks amazing thank you
damn you are good at heart dude yours is
freaking perfect what are you talking
about
like zoom up in there that's really good
yeah but yours is like way more accurate
mine's got like a
a janky like game asset version
got the thank you i appreciate it
yeah um the form of yours though
okay it looks so accurate like
schematic-wise
um i feel like i could have added a
couple more rungs to my like accordion
thing um uh
and like maybe it's just the angle of it
but like it feels a little long
i'm not quite sure i could probably
scale that back a tad but
yeah it's hard to judge what the
proportions should be it's such a
strange shape
and so i ended up like scaling it uh
forward and backward a lot it's good to
mess with it though you know
yeah definitely damn now i want to like
bring this into a substance
i know me too make it look nice this is
awesome
yeah i'm definitely going to do that and
put it on the patreon if anybody is uh
interested in having this asset shout
outs
oh shout outs painless plug do it
shameless
okay cool man um let's check out what
everyone else did nice
this was super fun dude
yeah man i think this totally worked
yours looks thank you
just now
andrew's in here wait we got blender
guru up in here
oh damn what's up andrew oh man
oh man the father my my blender father
oh my god i wouldn't be here without
angela i mean we have to do a quick
everybody here this is here we go um
damn i think we do have to do a quick
donut
all right five minute donut uh let's do
it
and then we'll take a look at everyone's
cameras
five minute five minutes that sounds
good you reset this
um let me know when you're ready peter
and we'll do i you know i've always
wondered how i would do the donut
in c4d yeah
okay uh yeah i'm ready okay all right go
all right i'm done
ah all right here we go here we go here
we go
andrew i never actually watched the
donut dude blast me i needs it
i'm gonna go watch it right now let's
see how the heck
i'm gonna this uh i guess at
a tube
it's this it's the the icing that's
going to be my challenge
yeah that's what i don't worry about
see we'll do the low poly version and
then
i'm smart
a little bit of
top down situation follow this mug
let's do like
something i'm gonna have to deform it to
the
the tube or to the to the um
uh to the torus that is called yeah
i just selected some faces on the torus
and like
duplicated them and now i'm just like
smoothing them out oh that's probably a
good way to go
um let's do
a little bit
yeah i'm just getting some random ones
oh no clicked
touch
why a donut ren
why a donut because blender guru is up
in here or he was was he is he still in
here
pretty freaking sweet um yeah i mean
that's what uh
a word from soto that's what i heard it
could be hearsay
but either way happy to uh
yeah it's going good it's
it's a little hairy donut right now
i guess ren's in the chat too that's
pretty sweet got everybody popping up
what's up friend
all right how do i deform this i know
there's like something in c4d
exactly for this um
like
line is it wrap surface
surface projection what's the surface
the surface is the torus
and we want this to go onto
that
and if we move this down will it just
work of course not of course not
initialize
uh
mapping oh oh oh oh
yeah that kind of works
oh my goodness like i know this is what
i need but
get up on this donut dude
yeah oh my goodness
dude what candy man
shrink it's shrink wrap it shrink wrap
thank you thank you everyone
we have 30 seconds ah
i forgot about five minutes i was used
to the 30 minute one okay shrink wrap
shrink wrap no you know what screw it
i'm making yeah i'm making a capsule
right now
let's clone this oh this is great real
quick
14 seconds dude object
uh what's the object it's the no it's
the
okay this is my janky donut
oh so bad
so bad andrew
wow okay you know what
shrink wrap okay bonus time
uh we got rap screw it shrink
crap boom
the target is
how do i do that i've never done this
before
um
shrink wrap the subdivision
surface
i have to put it inside of it
yes oh wait no
never used this before oh that's
horrible
what on earth dude
yeah yeah
boundary edge
uh
huh maybe i'm just doing it wrong
oh yeah here's my donut take a picture
of this this is just my donut right here
peter you're so good dude that's great
it's freaking great i love it man
i'm out of breath
[Laughter]
thanks
i don't know how this works i've never
used this
thing before along normals
source axis is that it
so bad i think we need some more uh
sprinkles all right look my okay my uh
donut is just a little stale the icing
in particular
that's how it's going
that i would take a bite
oh uh that's kind of like a voodoo
doughnut definitely
type deal yeah i
i'm just gonna say it i'm over voodoo
donuts love to them
much love but uh you know what it is i
i just like the cake doughnuts i don't
like those fluffy ones like this
like this kind of donut is like i'm an
old-fashioned
guy i like the old-fashioned donuts
those are great yeah um
dude we got we got render surrender up
in here
uh hell yeah
are we gonna do this with friend um like
with simulations or dynamics we gotta
actually do like a dynamics challenge or
something
it'd be crazy yeah okay that would be
i know 10 hours long just like us with
our
like our head and our hands the whole
time that was sick
um let's take a let's take a quick look
at everyone's fun uh
yeah yeah cameras
and then um yeah we'll wrap you up peter
and then i'll
do some art judging oh yeah um
you're gonna wrap me up i'm not as
confident i can't do that
i will not do that
[Laughter]
no i couldn't do that either one day um
okay let's get let's let's be real
on this uh that is good but that looks
like a downloaded model
but it was 30 minutes so who knows
the like chinese or the japanese
characters
for the camera
it's like the first real submission yeah
it looks like oh wow
really good
damn yeah that's incredible good wow
very good very good
oh my god yeah great drawing oh wow the
first
low bit one uh the 8-bit one is pretty
sweet
yeah that looks awesome yeah i hope the
box lies
classic sergio i think is like one of
the first ones that like kind of got
that shape down
um and then a thule definitely has it
too
oscar good to see all five or all six
rounds into one
yeah that's awesome amazing dude look at
this cameraman
[Laughter]
that's amazing it's so jacked the hands
oh that's awesome
zachary good stuff
oh i love the minimalism of uh max the
cool man yeah it's like boxy
the cartoony one is cool niz
yeah larry good stuff
what speed sculpting soft model clay
whoa what that's crazy that's amazing
i've never seen that hey i've seen like
digital speed sculpting but
not yeah that's physical that's
incredible x-ray did a good job it looks
like you did a sim on that like
on the little scrunchy part oh yeah
it might be the uh the blender cloth
sculpting
uh thing jarvis that's pretty cool
oh the cat takes a picture
i love that 8-bit style
such a fan yeah that's great
yeah that looks awesome really good guys
getting that shape down
um marv rice good work
very very good work mm-hmm
seriously yeah that's that looks
impeccable
wow good stuff everybody
yes the game is oh yeah yeah anthony
it's like from like one
yeah i'm actually modeling a bunch of
that stuff right now for my game that's
in that
style it's really fun
it's so easy these are so cool the
painting
mr jay super saiyan oh the painting yeah
really nice ooh durgo
really good mm-hmm
wait back the hack very nice man
wow yeah dang good stuff
yeah got all the gears in there and
stuff matthew solidwork
bingey boy it's just that that's quite
the uh the little accordion piece that's
great
bass that thing's good know right jack
has pictures
uh bass that's really good i like that a
lot
yeah absolutely
oh object objectitude is
solid very nice man
oh wow uh ed spin has the little thing
you throw over your head
that's amazing it's so good that's cool
belly very good
blender king wow that's nice
heck yeah
oh nice very nice
ooh h4 core i love the isometric
render i'm a fan of the isometric view
um crystal picks good stuff
piece of pizza yeah very nice
uh i love i love your art style every
time
yeah what's up what's up tank steal
hitch mitch wow dr pepsi where's dr
pepsi at
oh yeah good job on the lighting so cool
yeah what a nice scene
good stuff everybody everyone's getting
the shape down
mdk solid
raw worth that's good
dang the great murloc that's it's just
good render quality good lighting
you got the shape down
lots of good ones here lots of solid
ones here um
iberic i like your style yeah
hostile bunny pastel bunny that's really
cool
wow snake shock that's really good man
these are solid
yeah ooh mr tiffles
love that style red of paw very nice
huh uh did you see uh eca golds
yet it's like the cartoon style drawing
very minimal
and it's a picture of all five pictures
oh i gotta see that
he said yeah that's good that's good
stuff
oh that's awesome oh my god
i love that i gotta save that super good
bad banshee very nice
the potato oh my god
great wow coalescence
that's really good
denim solid work solid work
e2 very good model here wow that's
that's great
alan really nice will to thrill really
good
and everyone's nailing this one
yeah sorrow so many good ones says
uh really solid seb chen
really solid digging everyone's stuff
here
wow altitude really good axl explosion
really nice i'm always impressed when
people can like
make something minimal without it
feeling low effort you know
even though like it probably takes low
effort so it's really s
yeah smart way to do something it's hard
to have it look clean yeah it's kind of
clean
yeah clean so it's really having like a
solid color background
like a psych i think helps with that a
lot
um
tarjay this is really good i like that a
lot
man axle explosion my god
so good
heck yeah
oh somebody made a really good donut
they're solid
cheese camera no it's a bunch of donuts
donut town
wow these are great
so sick good job everybody hats off
ah yeah that's in the donut town we're
getting a donut town
good stuff everyone thank you so much uh
peter i appreciate you man
uh that was freaking sick yeah dude
thanks for bringing me all this was a
super fun time yeah absolutely it's
great um
so you got a youtube channel what is
that just peter france
yeah yeah my youtube channel channel is
just peter france go ahead and search
that if you like blend
two blender tutorials or other
shenanigans i'm actually going to start
posting devlogs for the vr game that i'm
working on so if that sounds
interesting to you definitely subscribe
i also have a patreon if you'd like
i put some 3d scanned assets and stuff
i'm working on up there
gonna be uploading a new pack tomorrow
probably
so uh yeah great to hang out with you
guys i love the community i love seeing
all these renders they're all so good
and uh yeah you just click you create a
very fun
space yeah it means a lot especially on
a saturday
um when people are usually not working
so thank you
peter for hanging out with me let's do
this again um it'll keep getting better
and better and uh hell yeah
yeah dude rock on um have a good rest of
your weekend man
yeah thanks man love you too all right
peace out
so um i'm gonna get into the
art review for the weekly challenge um
every single week we do weekly challenge
on the create with clint discord server
and this last uh challenge was falling
so i challenge you guys to make your
best falling render
and uh yeah you guys are about to see
the best five so let me
make sure nothing's queued up yet i want
to give anything away
and let's hop over into this art review
yeah boy let's do it
okay so we got five winners for y'all
today
uh the challenge was falling and
it's gonna be a good time i i really
appreciate y'all
doing this with me by the way um i think
it's freaking cool it's really fun
i want to do this once a month it's
totally a doable stream and it involves
everyone in a real unique way so
shout out to all you guys for sticking
with us we had a solid like
2400 people up in here for a while
and the numbers the numbers were good so
thank you guys so much thank you for the
super chat thank you for the support and
the whole point of this channel is just
to
keep learning and growing together in
our passions every single week
and that's what we've been doing for
about a year now a little over a year
um we've been doing this so thank you to
all you guys who've stuck in with me
um and made it awesome so
let's get into our weekly challenge
winners you guys are going to be getting
the discord
uh weekly challenge winner roll c on
the server we got 27 000 people up in
the discord server
it's growing in just a year a little
over a year it's crazy
so first up first winner for the
falling challenge is
uh jerome stefan with this
incredible animation of an astronaut
falling through space
passing a bunch of space debris
beautifully rendered beautifully lit um
your edge lighting
your astronaut and all your space debris
um vary in a very smart way
this allows for you to pick out the
shapes
of the astronaut of the rope of the
debris pieces
and it really stands out against the
black background
i love this so much congratulations
jerome you
are the challenge winner this week
you're getting that challenge winner
role
in the discord server to wear the badge
with pride
uh you deserve it man it loops your
render loops it's freaking awesome
um absolutely unbelievable
perfect quality movie quality i'd say
okay uh winner number two we got four
left all right
um so number two we have
bam hair zettle with this one i
love this one so much uh the color is
incredible
you fill the frame with the character
you actually have the sense of speed and
motion and it's built
into the actual geometry of the art here
um with the speed lines and everything
it's so cool i love your colors so much
in the way you lit it from
underneath really lets you just focus on
the character itself it's very stylized
very very well done so
congratulations airsettle for winning
this week's weekly challenge
you got the challenge winner roll wear
with pride hang on to it all right
you know because you might get it taken
from you next week but you got it for
this week
um i love this i love this so much i
like your
the lens distortion you have or not
distortion but like the lens grime you
have
i think is a really nice touch i think
there might be a little bit of film
grain in there too
it's looking really really cool um
so moving on to the third
winner for the weekly challenge this
week for falling the prompt was falling
is boom edward
super solid man um
i dig this so much it's stylized uh
it's centered symmetrical i really dig
it i like your
subtle colors here i like the way you
lit it from underneath you get a real
nice edge light on the character falling
down
you can really pick out the character
and the light's catching the glass
pieces perfectly so you get a story of
what's going on
well i think that's a briefcase it's
hard to see from this tiny
view i'm looking at this in obs but um
i love this so much telling a cool story
with this man
very very nice very good stuff
congratulations edward you're getting
the challenge winner role this week as
well now if you guys want to participate
in the weekly challenge as well um once
i get through these we're going to
decide
the challenge together so probably do
like a straw poll situation like we've
done in the past
one of which will probably be combining
all six renders
that we created here on the stream to
use
in um in your weekly challenge or two
other things we'll figure it out
it looks like spider-man doesn't it yeah
it looks like spider-man but if you zoom
in
don't think it is but who knows
what do i know um moving on we got two
more winners
for this week's weekly challenge only
two more left
who's it gonna be winner number four for
the falling prompt is
bam bobby riggs really cool stuff this
is very unique
i think a couple people have been doing
uh
these like comic book style covers and i
don't know if it was you bobby
last time um it may have been
but i love this vibe so much it's really
cool it's very well done
it's designed perfectly it's lit
perfectly it's framed perfectly the
color is really nice it draws the eye to
the center point it fills the frame
um yeah it's just all around super solid
and it it answers the prompt yeah in a
really cool way
in a very unique way
i love it i love it congratulations
bobby you're getting the challenge
winner roll
this week it's good to do this again you
know it's it's been probably about a
month
since i've done the weekly challenges
live like this
and it's definitely the way to go
all right and last but not least
everybody
we got one more weekly challenge winner
and then i'm gonna get
i'll get into some honorable mentions
alright so last but not least
we have
bam sid conscious i believe is the name
and this kind of started halfway through
but you know it loops so
let's just uh go for the ride here
we got a character falling into bed
and this here is the beginning bam
super cool
i love the way it's lit the volumetric
lighting revealing different elements as
you go further
into the ocean as you go deeper
absolutely beautiful that's so cool we
got the car
jellyfish action it's cool how it
silhouettes the main character
i love that the main character's still
glowing too
maybe here be a little nice to have the
character glow a little bit or something
or have a little bit more light but
that's so nice the way it silhouettes
the character
and falls right back into bed
and that's what happens sid conscious
every single night
so freaking cool amazing congratulations
to all the challenge winners this week
guys thank you so much
for doing some cool stuff so i don't
have the honorable mentions
queued up but i can actually
show them here on my screen for you
give me one moment because there are
some really cool ones that i want to
show you guys and talk about um
let's see
okay let's give these guys let's hide
these guys
in fact we'll rise up and
bam all right so one at a time
and it's gonna be a little crazy here
but yeah we got this one here by uh
annie kett
and i think this is the first time
aniket submitted
but i really like it i like the style
your lines are super solid
very symmetrical and it's very easy to
focus on
the main subject here which is an
on-duty police officer jumping out the
window i wonder
why there's a little bit of story going
on too
so i dig that any kit that's good stuff
next
up um we got we got
eel king of course
uh you know dropping dropping that phone
right up in that toilet it's not good
you know it is not good
luckily this has never happened to me um
but eel king maybe it's happened to you
apologies it's a rough life but it made
me laugh
so shout outs man good stuff
uh be pete
really cool in here
yeah i like your style here it's very
minimal
you got the fog you know you got the
light from the top matrix style
the hands at the bottom
really cool render i dig the style
congrats man keep up the good work
next up utkarsh kumar
with the indiana jones themed
submission here i dig it it looks like a
photoshop
situation i can't tell if it's concept
art or what but
it's really good it's super good
um i like your lighting feels like i'm
there
you got the motion blur in the right
spot too i'd say that's pretty perfect
dude karsh congrats man shout outs good
stuff
i know is next with this super cool one
um
is really cool yeah i dig this one a lot
let's go obs come on got a character
falling out the airplane
don't worry he's got a parachute it's
all good but i like your colors i like
your style
render quality is very nice your
lighting is very good
um this one came close this one came
pretty darn close
so congrats
uh d god is next with this one here
super cool definitely like album art
uh material it looks really good
got the hands coming down at the bottom
catch this person
and your silhouetting or i'm sorry
you're vignetting the character
naturally with the dark clouds which is
a solid move
i like your colors good stuff
asica next this one i love
it's very video gamey i like your
composition a lot
i like what you're doing again focusing
the attention to the characters
one by silhouetting them so they're
contrasted from the background
background's lighter they're darker you
also have the
cliff side on either side of the frame
um
really training your eye to that center
piece there um
and it looks like it's a render from
nausicaa
in the valley of the wind which is i
think
miyazaki's first or second movie
um solid stuff really good i love it
noobs 3 is next
with this beautiful piece of art
rendered very nicely got some mega scans
assets in there
you probably didn't need the tree
you know because my eye is already
guided towards the millennium falcon in
the background you could probably crop
drop this out a little bit just frame in
just a little bit
but it's really nice i like your colors
a lot and your inner quality and
lighting is very good
so congrats one
dead duck is next always putting out
good stuff
this one's super cool just a solid piece
of art here
beautiful clouds very very beautiful
super solid scene this one came very
close as well
sick sick we're about halfway through
got some more honorable mentions to
shout out this one's super cool
very creepy i would not want to be on
that boat or
anywhere in this scene um which is a
good thing because he made me feel
pretty sketched out i love it
i love it you got some rain you got some
film grain
it's looking really good so congrats
peach kill
a good one soul nate is next this one's
awesome
i made a comic strip super funny i love
the different take on it
i love your art style um
it felt very fresh and it made me laugh
so i say that's a good thing congrats
man
good stuff soul mate
zephyr is next
one's pretty sweet this one came close
um falling through the top
uh window of an apartment building not
chill
not good at all but i wanted to give a
shout out to zephyr because this
is a solid render very very good stuff
i love your color i love how you're
silhouetting the main character to bring
attention to them
you got a little bit of fog in the
background to silhouette them a little
bit
um i'm sorry silhouette i'm at edge
light you're hitting with the edge light
from up top
very nice very good stuff
anto abhishek is next
i thought this was uh this wasn't bad
here let me loop it real quick
it go here we go
i thought it was when i was watching it
on discord it looked photo real for a
second
this is a mr ant i think
and this dude has come so far so so far
in such a small time period
i just wanted to shout out this artist
anto abhishek
mr ant and say congrats for
keeping up with everything for sticking
with it
and for uh yeah
we're continually coming back and
learning man that's the whole point of
all this stuff so good job
good work uh kareemi
oh geez i'm gonna mute these i just
don't know exactly
yeah this one's really good let's loop
that one more time
classic miximo character on the onewheel
really nice animation there with the
pizzas
it's good stuff very good stuff i love
this one a lot this one came close as
well
uh let's see ness
is next apologies for the sound y'all
i'm going to loop this real quick
this one's super cool really intense
this one came close as well but i love
the style of the colors i love the
camera
it's not too jarring i just wish it
looped that's the only thing i just wish
it looped
but ness this is really good
very impressive your animation's solid
your camera animation is really good
you should be proud um
and two more we got time for two more
this one is absolutely ridiculous
like quite the take on the prompt
these like soft body gummy characters is
so cool
amazing simulations
so sick very very good stuff
soft body dance no name on that one just
named soft body dance and then the last
one is the game factory
goodness apologies y'all
sorry for the ears
but i love this one you know you got the
dance going popping off and you're like
well where's the fall
i don't know how this pertains to the
prompt and there you go
and that's it that's it y'all thank you
thank you for joining me let's figure
out this next weekly challenge real
quick
before we dip out um
so i'm gonna make a straw poll link
that i will drop into that i'll pin to
these uh
the live feed real quick
so i need two prompts from y'all
um we'll use peter's suggestion
using all of the models to create a
scene uh so what would i call that
use speed models to create
a uniform
unified scene or use speed models to
create a
story yeah so that'll be one
and i'm looking for suggestions here
on the weekly challenge what do you guys
want to do
throw it down for me
h so we've done nature and sci-fi
already
sleep have we done sleep
sword sleep and sword aren't bad
um i'll i'll take it down to a couple
here
and we'll we'll vote on these sleep i'm
actually down for i think that could be
a cool one
sword could be fun
people like sleep okay cool
um skate very nice
factory oh man factory could be intense
that's a lot of work
okay you've done oh you've done dream
okay we've done dreams so maybe sleep is
a little close but
i feel like dream is i don't know maybe
we can still get dream
weather weather could be interesting
storm
i think we've already done storm it's
hard to remember at this point we've
done so many
music have we done music
um mods i'm looking to you guys to see
which ones we've done light
time i think we've done time
have we done time jazz
interesting
underground ah interesting hair
deep
deep could be cool okay all right we've
done time
uh deep could be interesting
hmm we didn't do music
maybe music music
or deep since we've already done dream
we could do
instead of sleep maybe we could do music
so what do you guys think about music
and deep and then use the speed models
to create a story
i'll do one last look over here we've
done caves
um we've done steampunk already i think
factory would be a lot
gravity could be sweet actually
music all right i'm calling it i'm
calling it right here
we have use the speed models to create a
story we have music and we have deep
so let me create this poll and i'm going
to
pin it really quick
all right so everyone chill out here
posting because i'm going to need to pin
a comment
actually now i can still do it i am
all right so go to the pinned message
it's the straw poll link
and vote on what you guys want to do
for the weekly challenge this week
between using the speed models we
created on this stream to create a story
music or deep and those are your three
choices
and i'll give it two minutes here
and we'll see what we're gonna do
all right the votes are coming in we got
89 votes
hundred and something votes 120 votes
coming in it looks like
it looks like the winner is pretty clear
here i'll give it another minute
the link is pinned to the live chat
right now
vote on the weekly challenge
that was a fun stream guys thank you so
much thank you sodamonte for uh
for moderating and doing all the
the images and the challenges for peter
and i was amazing
very very helpful thank you for being
here the whole time to the other
moderators
saw ronan i saw a visual up in here
thank you guys for your time
always appreciated
all right guys it's looking like the
winner is pretty darn clear
with 51
52 of the votes
uh out of 225 votes it's looking like
deep is going to be the weekly challenge
this week alright so you guys have one
week
to make a render based off of the prompt
deep uh and since
next week is going to be an edited video
i'm going to be announcing
the new community challenge it's going
to be a month-long community challenge
very similar to the alternate realities
challenge in the sense that it's a month
long
i'm going to combine them all into a
montage we're going to judge them we're
going to give out some prizes
um it's going to be freaking awesome
again
and yes it's right after alternate
realities
so this one's gonna be very unique it's
gonna be very different um
and i'm very excited to see what you
guys can do i just can't wait to tell
you about it
one more week you guys will find out and
it's gonna be sick um
i'll answer any questions you guys have
over the next five minutes and then i'm
gonna get some lunch
so just hit me here at punisher in the
chat and i'll see what i can do
sarah van thank you for your time thanks
for hanging out
good stuff man that was a fun one yeah i
want to do this
this format once a month i think it
could be really cool we can do a bunch
of different stuff with it
what was the favorite model i did today
well i kind of
surprised myself with that sea creature
but i'd probably have to say
the camera was probably my favorite it's
the one i felt i did the best on
uh the worst one for me probably eiffel
tower
yeah that was bad vfx king can you start
the weekly challenge now yes you can
cody how long have i been doing vfx man
since i was
in ninth grade 2004
probably yeah
eighth grade 2004 i started
by adding muzzle flashes to individual
frames
in like a program called macromedia
fireworks
and i would save that out bring it into
windows movie maker
and attach it to like my little airsoft
guns
those were the first vfx i did
when is the next unreal engine stream
maybe unreal engine 5.
uh that is a good question i have a lot
of stuff planned for the future
here especially with this new community
challenge coming out but i do have
a unreal engine 5 breakdown coming out
probably next month um i'm going to
create
a scene that i have in my head and have
it look as photo real as possible and
show you guys
all the steps that i went through to
creating that art very similar to the
art breakdown i did last week
but it'll be an unreal engine
big chungus what's up dude yo uh
mostly colin when were you able to quit
your day job
or did you go to college and straight
into the industry
okay so when i was in georgia
i was working at a
uh a hibachi restaurant of course i was
working at a hibachi restaurant
i was a server um i worked there for
about a year
and i was going to college to a
technical college at the time
and i was also doing vfx freelance
and i was able to i mean i basically
dropped out of college left that job and
drove out to la
to move in with freddie and
he charged me super cheap rent like
super cheap rent
and i was just able to create i think i
was working on cardboard warfare 2 at
the time
when i was with freddy and i would help
him
on vfx with his shorts so i would you
know he would pay me for that as well
um and then yeah it just kind of it took
off from there
you know i worked at rocket jump for
probably three years
took a year off doing freelance and then
i did corridor for three years
and it's been like three or four months
on my own now
and it is it's been insane how
fast this channel has grown how much the
community has grown
you guys have been coming back
consistently i really
obviously couldn't do it without you all
and i have some seriously large plans
for this channel in the future you'll
know about it this month
i'm working hard i just got so much on
my plate
um and i'm trying to do a lot trying to
do a lot so
um i mentioned a patreon coming out
that's gonna help me
bring on a couple more people and
keep making content that you guys are
enjoying that's high quality
so it's not just me i can only do so
much on my own so the patreon is going
to help with that it's also going to
give you guys some really cool incentive
um to want to sign up you know some
exclusive stuff
it'll be really cool um i got a ton of
videos planned
for later this year um like i said the
next weekly or
the next community challenge which is a
month-long challenge with the montages
at the end
that's going to be announced next week
so lots of big stuff coming out
adam how do you get inspiration to make
anything
good question um
well i think i enjoy creating stuff
naturally i enjoy being creative
so that that helps um
i think it comes from these challenges
from doing things
from seeing things out in the wild and
wanting to just challenge myself let's
try something
um also you know the images i see in my
head
i want to tell certain stories i want to
get like certain vibes i love traveling
going on trips inspires me a lot
putting on music that fits the kind of
vibe of the location i'm at helps a lot
music actually helps me come up with
ideas a whole lot
i'll be able to see something in my head
when i'm listening to ambient music or
any song really but usually ambient
music helps me
um it immediately puts me in a place
puts a picture of my mind
and from there you know start coming
with stories and just writing down your
ideas and being aware of
all the ideas that come in and out of
your head right
writing stuff down is very helpful
so yeah i'll answer a couple more
questions and then i'm a bounce i'm
getting some lunch here
do i plan on making merch um
i don't know we'll see making merch
we'll have to see about that right now
the only thing i offer physical things
that i offer are prints
so my print store is in the description
of this video it's noise grain and
light.com i have some limited edition
prints
i have some renders but mostly film
photography
i'll be posting some more renders to uh
noise grain and light pretty soon
um but yeah in terms of t-shirts like
maybe
i don't know it depends on if everybody
wants t-shirts but i'm not
not trying to print a bunch of t-shirts
you know maybe some stickers
i think some stickers could be cool
um and big j what are your thoughts on
workbench and blender do you think it's
bad or do you think it's perfectly good
rendering format for tech machines
i don't know what workbench is because i
don't use blender
i apologize my man
what else do we got
i don't speak german no
okay hey alan that's a good question how
do you know which ideas are good enough
and realistic to pursue that's a great
question
so i think once you have a list of like
ideas that you want
to create you want to pursue i think you
need to ask yourself like
for me i want to direct movies so
pursuing a film is on my plate
it's being written right now um working
with a writer on that
but how do we decide what movie we want
to make and uh
nate that's his that's his name the
writer nate davis
he was like yo um we need to come up
with a bunch of ideas
and we'll pick the one that
that reaches that calls out to us that's
like oh that's a great idea
let's do it you know i think you'll know
it's like
but when you hear something that you
really like it's kind of like a light
bulb going off
but really what he said was
we need to create something that we're
okay living with
for the next two years because it'll
probably take two years to make the
movie in terms of
writing it filming it and doing
post-production on it
you need to be still passionate about
what you're doing
after working on it for two years
imagine working on a render for two
years
like you better love that render you
know what i'm saying
you don't want to get bored of it so
that was a big thing for us is making
sure that we weren't going to get tired
of the characters the story the vibe or
you know within that two-year time
window
in terms of like smaller projects
like the last one i did for the
alternate realities challenge the
post-apocalyptic
vibe how did i know that was an idea
worth pursuing um
you know for me i love you guys know i
love foggy atmospheric stuff
and i love abandoned buildings so
i've always wanted to do a render
kind of based around an abandoned
building or an abandoned
landscape so that was my time to do that
that just came from me wanting to be
inspired
um you have to ask yourself too what are
you gonna learn throughout the process
are you doing this like what are you
gonna
are you gonna gain anything from this uh
for me
it was a piece of content i was able to
make a breakdown for
the alternate realities uh piece of art
that i did
um i'm also into nfts as well so i'll be
able to make an nft from that
so it's not just the process the
learning process
it is being able to share it and make
cool stuff for the world as well
right so it's kind of a bonus on top of
that
um if you think it'll be good for your
real good for your resume
that's another thing too um
but that's a very good question how do
you know an idea is worth pursuing
another one too is is it unique
is it a story that needs to be told is
it an image that
people don't usually see every day and
you know gets people to do a double take
like whoa that's pretty sweet
when you know at rocket jump or at
corridor coming up with a viral video
it's difficult to come up with a viral
video but
it's interesting with both the flores
lava
video i did a rocket jump and the boss
town dynamics video i did
at corridor for both of those i knew
just the idea alone it would at least
get a million views
because it's unique hadn't really been
done before in that certain way
and i knew i would execute it uh
i knew that i would execute on the idea
to the best of my ability and it would
be good
so if you have that idea in your head
that's unique
the world hasn't kind of you know really
seen yet and feels
very personal to you and you're
passionate about it then that that's
that's a solid idea and that was a very
long answer
but with that y'all i'mma bounce thank
you
thank you so much for joining me thanks
for modeling stuff with me that was
really fun we got to do this again
and uh yeah thanks for your guys support
thanks for the super chats and
everything
uh stay tuned next week all right
big announcement the next community
challenge is popping off
all right so we're going to create some
really cool stuff together once again
we're going to pack it together in a
really
really sweet montage i'll give you a
clue as to what it is
the aspect ratio is
flipped so it's a vertical
video kind of montage maybe that give
you guys some ideas
but thank you so much catch you guys
next week and uh have a good week good
luck on the weekly challenge
peace out y'all have a good one
oh i once again almost ended it without
going to the end screen
see you guys soon
[Music]
ten
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you